YOEAR A SENTI,ST THE
PRINSOESR  D THEENAREPTMOFT
PS
GYHOYCLOT A SDNFTAOR
SIIVUNER ATYND DR ECIRTOOF THE
RDANSTFOR EN CTERFODUEP RROBLCIE
TORIMET  S.ENCICE
CECI SEN
HRIS RH,EAESRCIMEU NROINAGG
STND UERDANT THAHE TRA B
IN
SY UEMSTSERLYG
SIDECIIN-MONAKEXANG D EUTECIV
FUNDONTI A TLS AO AHEHOUTRF O
20THE K B18OO THE ND MEWIN
RE WERADSEN HETHNGMA IGIAN CND A
CAEA ROTEVL OBO AUTUR
TH
TSGH.
HEIS TWEL FLOTICI SENTH ISTN E
DE OMERTNTCH PFSY AOGOLY
T
RVHADARVE UNI
ITRSY.
IT LSIE A TTHESENT IERIOCTN O
SIDECIONIN MAK,INONMO ETI AND
GHTONIY  TTHEELLWI BCU DISINSSG
THES LAT BOOAR HOD TREAK
TILICITA BVENCLLRIIA AEND
AITEENRTNDNGNI AHE T BOTKOO N
ONLY DAIETLSHE TS AB HITOF
ALVIDIDU BSUTLSOIS DSSCUESIN
THESSMAIV SLIEOCTAAB HIT
ANGE N WEDEE TOSSDD ARE T
HI
CESGGTGELLHAEN OSF OURE. TIM
ATHAUORNDCH PSYTOGOLIS AELNGA
WODUCKAIH RTPR TSSEK BHEOO
GITWRINHES A TAR REEN SCISTTI
WHANO C TUS PHNT FHERORIEF O
LEKNOWRWE DGFOD A ALSOEA RCH
,BACK HFF OERISAN HD H ANDPEELD
H
REE STF OTCS  UCAH UP.
LERE A PEDASO TT HOS THIWE
WT ENSOHOITUTERUR FTH, ADOSEV
TH
TADIE GILIU PODMS I.OU YRS
YHA TNKOU SOUC M
'SITN HONOR FORO TE BER HEND A
HOIS DNSSSCUIO WYHIT M
TILONGLE CMEOL
UEAG.
IM AT JUS GNGOI TO GHROU AGH
ESSERIUEF O Q AIOSTNSR  HNDEA
AY
ITLETT B OF HHA WT THAE S
TAAND KEOU YRUESTNST AHE T
D.EN
WN KVENOSE RUSCE SLLIN H WAS
UAGRA ADDE STETUNT A LTLITEOR M
2ANTHS.YE0 AR
I'OIOT N G TNGOAY S HOW LGON
HAATT  TE TTIMVE EN A A GRAD
T
HENUDT,E WASOI DNG SEOMF O
E VIRYER FDI SSTTUES L
KG
HEAT TIOEL RATOFHINSP HE T
TAESPRENFONTI O LAB HITGRNEAIN
B TINHEOINRA SE'S BOINEE D
H
ISS THI E CIRNTEANEEARR ISD
FEON O E THE IERXPTSNER TMS OF
THMAHUN BRAS INOFIRHE T FST
TIQUESAV ION HISE  WHYID D YOU
ITWRS TEHIOO BK WOW N,THA
TIVAU D TEYOTOO DS THIOO B
KAN
PSEND CAATULESHA WTOU'VE
BEOI DNGR YOUNT EEIR CEER?
IT>> S IUN FO T HEAV A
USDISCBOONSI AS TUTHI WHIT Y.OU
N'SIT AER INTTIESNGST QUEN.IO
MOO TKONAE  LG TOEIM TEEC DID
ILDOUTE WRI AOO BKT ALLND A
H
T FIE RSOKBO I WTERO WAS
ECABEUST F IEL IIK LEAD H
A
TY ORTONDLEL AIHE TN  WASHE T
I
RST GHPEONLLO  TTE A ITND I
LTHE TE SAMAY W A TUTBO
A
SET O QNSSTUEIO IEEAD H BN
KITHINUT ANGBO LOR F AGONIM TE
E D ANTHE RKWO WDD DIANSTH OER
VE DADEON MT A E LOOFRO PESGRSHA
AN L TINHETASEW F CEA YRSINOMG
OU T TOFHEUEHNECIQLEPES OP
HAEE BNOPEV DELNDGIN A IT
IKEDEM L TEHE TIG RHT
E O
ITWRES THIOO BKON NTH OEF  HAD
OR STF O GE IEO NTTH OEP DTHF
BIE THHAT  TTSHAGHTHI OUTAS W
SSNECEORYAR FNEOM SEOO T
RSUNDEHENDTA WY TREHEAM CEM. FRO
>> WOHOS IS THIK BOOOR F WN
ARU EEA RNGDI IT, WHON IOU YR
T WNDASHEEA RRDE OFHE T BK?OO
FIT 'SORNEOM SEOSHA TT'OT N
AT
T XP EERTBUWS KNOTL L AIT
IANDSER INTTEESD IEAN LINRNG A
T LOREMOBO AUT HOW TSEHE T
S
AWORK'T INDSNAI AFRD O YF,OU
KNE S,OMOFOR ST HI SOPEDICSTAT
SCENCNGRI WTI
DELINEFITY TRYO TEE KTP IS A
IBCEACSSLE ASOS PBLSIE B IUT
SN'DOT AHYYWATHRO FM AI DEET
L
THATS IES NECORYSA TSTND UERDAN
ESW HOTHENG THISK. WOR
>>XPLASOINING TH OMEF EES
TE
ESNICHQUK B AOO WANY M
TSUDSTENO T PEA RDLYTIARAL
ITUSCAE S I ARE G BOO OF
HA ABUT TECOLS BSEAU YOU DO A
JGOODLA EOBXP IININGHEINT  T
WAYHA TTHE TTSXP EER WLDOU
UN WTARSNDOECHHI D'TSN
SERPSURIVEE  MGINOU YRRYIS HTO
WSO ITANO TOW N STA WITH THE
BACS.
IHE TRESOR S OTF W F AEWSAY
TOEEF DINHE TM.
SOTUF  OINY,IVITELHIE W T
F
S IT AA STF OTI ROU ONER
THGS WE A DOICOMUTATLYAL.
KELIIL WAMAMLI JESALKED
T
TSHABI WNHE WE HTEROBO AUTM THE
80HE T 1E W0SER ALL TF O
HE
INROUTOU WESE TGHO TAKEUR S
EE
'T DONTOAV HE HI TNK AUTBO
EM.
THE EORESPSSAC MNDNEHI ALS AOO
F PETY OINTHGSHA TAI RTEMTHN E
TH IMEN E WNLDOR IALEN GERND A
O
YO, U KW,NOHE TNO IRES EE ND
RFOOS U TOR S OTFONTI TENUO
THTABK OUACT I EHE. TIM
, T OT HAIS WNEAYO THI TNKO
ABTSHAT BIS I STORHEF O T
ROHAEIN T WEUGHTO TAK M
E
CABEF,EUS OSEEC BAUE W D'T
NE
T TEDONKHIBO AUT TM,HE
ECABEUS THE W RLDOR'SAINI
MEE THSA AS  INDT'ANPOIMRTTOT
EPKE IND MINHE TRE ISETNE O S OF
THT TGSHA'T DON CNGHAE LE
THYOU KIN AUTBORI DUTNGVI BO ALS
PLTHE UE ACYO IAR PK
THN E
INPARKGEGAG RAVE ERYAY DESHA CNG
FRAY DAY TOD THEIN BRA S
S
FO ABIHATREIS DNCTIT TRO FMHE
BRSTN AISYATS EMTHLL AOW U TSO
CO
SLCINSOUMBREY ME THEVENTS
ATTHNEAP HPED AT' TNDHAT SORF O
N
EITTUIVSEEC BAUE W OAVENFT H
H
LIEES SCA WPSE MET N'REFERMB I
WEOCKE D TDHEROOR OOT NO S
TH
NE'SAT ONDAY W ANO AERTHAY
IN
CIHE T SSTIENST FORUSOC ME
ASIT HO TO D HIT WHY  TOWHEEAR
NERADND AHY W SHE TY OTOR
F
RONGHA AD UNSO WHY W DOE DO
TH I AGSNDN GERENALHE TIR FST
METI WE DET SOOMECNGHI BESEAU W
HA A GL OAININ MDIK L IEO GO T
ETHGEEF RRI BTORAR IAUECSE
ANSTIRY  IAN WT SNGETOMHI TO'MTH
INK.
TAL CLGOT HAA AL DIR
TEED
VIBEHA BORUTF I OMER VETI
SOMEING ONTSGE DR  OEVEDAN
GAEROV A C IINTRT SANTA
TO
SIBALLYAKE ON AOFIF LE TS I
NOWUC SASH T F I IN'IST
RTIMPOTANRENY AMO THEISRG OANM
STINBEG WIIEUDD LL SLLTIO DHE T
SOINTHG  ITOE DAT'TSN MRTE
ORANYMTHBUE T MP'SAT ITAORNT F
R
WHTHAT'SNUON CTIEDO T HGAN
OUARNDAU BECSEHE WN IT D
ST
MATT ANYVEREMO E I INFTS GOE
AWEEOU Y KGDOP IN IWA ATNYY.
ND A W ITHA'TSN A HITAB?
OAHE T GLIR DTED BRAVEHIOS I
WINTHGSEO DO TIE ACH AVEOA GL
WE
NK THIENF O G AALERLYSOT N
HATS AT  TNDHA B TISHEIG
INDIST TIOCTN WTHAEAK ME.
THNOW  DE'ERS AATEBESUTBO
YACEXTLRE WHERAO T DLITHW E NE
BUTHAT B T'SHEIGIF DEREFENC
O  IEN DINMESOTHG
IT WHWH
INTEIONAR TOW ADSL GOA THAST'
H
T WATEFNKHI OS AOT N AEI BNG
HABI
DVE ERYS IAYT'BI C AOM
N
OFHE T
WO T.
TAYOU  ALKOT L AUTBOAM DOPE.IN
OPPOY UNRTITTO TKAL A LTLITEIT B
ABWHT YT' I I SSONTORMPTAOR F
BIHATND A IL WIL Y ASKEW AOU F
REMOST QUENS.
>> KHEIM KARSHNIA
SMTRAN
TEITR.
HYSO WS  IIT SOOR IMPNTTA
ODEREVYBNK TYHITOFS  IVIS  AHA
O
GTHMEINOO T DIT WHURLE PAS OER
E
RDWAND AT IER CINTALYS I
TERELA BDUT WHA WTEAVEE' LEDRN
NC'SIT IYDIREBLEXOM CPL.
THE'SY MANREIF DFEES TNTYPF O
E
S PTCEOR B TINHEINRA I ANDT
DO
FE DESIFHINTRE TNSNG I
TERFFEN BAR PTSH  WUTITTSPREEC
TOIT HAB I TS,HENTORMPTATSP AEC
IST  THAEN WRECEE IVAEW RDAR
NCOR E SNTOUERNGETOMHIN I T
HE
DRL TELTHA TWE ULSS RE AOI GNG
A GTOETD EW RORAUATTH CSSEHE T
ASRELEOPOFE  DINAME, AND'SHE TRE
--N WHEEE  WARNG GOI T TOUHRGH
D WORLFNDKI OINHO COSGHA W TTO
OFON, E AYHE T WSHA TPE HTAPNSDO
C TISHEIONEONCTNRO FM
UR O
BRCERETE CALORN DXOWURO T O
GAA LIIS AOR STF OPE COMNGTI
WI A OTHNE LTHNOERETEIK L'SAY S
CII DE D TDEOO G IO OEF LTRD A
T.RIGH
THOISE' G TNGOE B OP SNETE
SANG NO,EF L ATNDHE T OERTH
GYISANGO.IG RHT
ONF OHE TM ISNG GOI TO WNDIN A
LESAY BYN THE W EEND UP IN A
OD PCE A E TTHENDF O THE
RO
'SATOI GNG TSE COAUOME
MIPANEO TE B RDEAELSEND A
E
HEOF TNG THI K WSEWNOT  INESDO I
THSABALGL GANIASN WHEHE T
NESON FOGEIR TATHEETR  THE
SA
TMEEIMAUT I CES SETH
ECCONNTOONTIS ET G ATR SGONO S
BE TUSCAEYHE H GEAV AATREERM
LI
ODLIKEHONNF  OWIATG INTH
ETCOMPYOIOITN L WUILREE  BMO
LI TLYOO D THE TT'NGHI IAS
FRTSO OXP EONNALATILE CALDHE T
LA
FFOFW  ETEC WS CHHI IFEON O
THSTMOIO OBVR EUSVEIFIK LE
UO D SNGETOMHITND A IIV GES
OOUYO GFSTD UFOU YOIE'R GNG TO
IDOT MEORFT O.EN
ROATTH PANDEVIS  EXPNATI
ON
VE WATE'NO KWNEV FOR.ER
S Y>>OUS IAYT'LLOT N A AUTBO
SUPLEA.
SOTHA PO DPLEOEET GNG WRO?
>> RIT'SBLSOEANA WHYEOPL
EAE
IND ULTHKT' IS WNG B
NOFTE THETIIT SUAONHE W
NEPADOMIINS  IBEGEL R ASEEADRE
ATSITUELNSIO ROEDAT TSHI TNG
LEPEOPIN FDURLE PASLEAB BUT THE
CTSTDIINHANIO TPOS T'IMTOANRTT
MABE IKES EEN, ANDHISS I
DE
DLOVEPEE Y  BTHISIESCNTTN
ANCHMIIGHO WE CAMP UH WITHI TS
INDISTBEIOCTN LIEETWN NGKI A
NA
INNTGND A OENSE THOSHI TNG
MOET TDOGUTRHE BURT I T ONSUT
NATTH I TIN BHERAHE CYCAMILL
EY DO'TON S COU YEEAN ST THA
IF YOU GONDN I AOR STF O
LANIMAPU ANDEEHA WPE HTAP
O
T I TUTNSUR OET L'SAY ST I
ODUC DYSONNCFUTIT IUR TNS
T OUATTHT I'TOE DSNLLCT AUA
T  WOMHAWE CANEL TLOS LE ITSYFR
ABILY TER EOXPNCIEEAS PLEEUR
AN T CWEANLELHA TT BY TOYHE D
REARCHHE WRE VHE TYHEEOID T
FAS OFAT RS AND SEEERHE WTH
W  SEYHOOUESTHE ARTWD SIG ONSF
REEAPLSUE LIK LKINGHE TIR
FIDS ERANHELL A TSED KINF O
AINTHGSTU INDT SRN OUTT THA
RA WOPSEHO DSYINAME EMSTAS H
BEENEP D BSSREEDLYICASALTI SLL
SHHELL A TWA OUTNS SRDIGF O
REEAPLSUHAUT B W DTHT EY'TONO
GIS TWOO RKOOOET G FOD SOUF I Y
MA ITAL AT DIFFULT FOR
O EMTH TTGEOM S THIETNGIKYHE L
H
'T WEYONO D IT SHEO TMEBEY CO
RTA SOF O CCHOU PATOTOHIO S TS
HAEDS LO T THEDE IT  TAHA'SIT
ANPOIMRT SNOT TO MUCH FORHE T
PL
BLSUEARACTASE PE OSFEW RDAR
BUTHE TTINC IEN AVEECSPTS AT I
ITTSFI WHS THI TDE IA WTHAE
W
OTOMFR LPE OSF ALLEOP TNGKI
ABCTADT DIN IOATOM SE PENTOI W
KNT I PLAYS AEN CALTR ROL AND
SWHENYEBOMODESEC BOMTEDD AIC
D
OT'SIT NS AF I TY A
INCONTO NGUI THEKETA TG DRUO T
THEY ANG DREOIS I CINTIONNU TGO
GEK BTACHEO T WREHE TY STAEDRT
ANFRTPA O IHA TTENDRS IVY B
ISTH STORF SONGNGRA CVIND A
E NTCEIVINETH K ODFAN WNGTI
YATOU F GETHEMRO TESHA CNG I
N
ETHYS SM.TE
>>OBO AUTTIDD AIC IONST IUS J
A
IT HAB I,SHE TE MREORO T IT
TH
ANHA TT?
ITH ISAS ON CSIOVTRERIC TALOP
RITOW N.
PMANYPLE INKTF O IINS  ABEG
OUABIT HTABSUT B LKOOT A
HAT
HAPPS AIT WHONICDDTIE W D'TON
THLLUAY KIN OFT I BS ANGEI
KIF O FEXILEBL SFTOR O
VIBEHA.OR
WENK THIF I ITSHE T WHI TNGE
TITOAUMALLCAYIN DO ITUAONTI
FTBU IOU YOO LKT AAYHE T W
LEPEOPHA TTREDD ATEICD TO
UGDRS GBOO AIN TUTRYTOG  OAIBTN
DRY TS,HEEARE A REAY LLCRVETI
DANT SOR OFLE F BBLXIERSAVEHIO
TH'T DATON LKOOE LIK HITABS AND
I OSONEADEHA TST'EL DEVEDOP
THT S'SORFEDEL RATHEO T T
IDTHS ATOM CERO FMAR HRDVAND A
END IS DEDELEVOPIDHI TS
EH
IATTHT MIG B TEHE GLOA OF
G TTGEINBEUGDRS THMECOS EIT HAB
ANACTHD E AKALTU TFGIN OHE T
SNUGDR I'TYEA RLLAB H.
ITHE TIN KDTTF  OGEGIN
ND A
INWANT BTHG ATESEC THEAB H.IT
>>, OKAY YOUSE U TD WHEOR
KYSTIC I L AOTNOU YR BK.OO
ARWHY E H SITABSANCKTIY DT WHA
DOOU YEA MN?
LA>> THELRGY ATARHE TY LYREE AL
ORDHA T G RETID OF.
TKELIYHE'T DONAYO  GAWN OHE TIR
OWNVEND A EWHENOURY TO T
GECHAN IHE TMST' CHAENGI ANGND
ENEYTH TOMTOD  CBAE CKO
SERTHE'USAR VIOTOAY WS RNS AWE
INI THUTEVK OLLYNAIORI WHY IES W
GELILLRAY DGUR DINTIVO ELUON
IVWE LEDN I EMEIRNVONSNT TT
CDNDI'TANNGHAE  NHEYWRESREA A
FA
ASTS THELD WORESHA CNG RHT
SONOW DET  IMASE SENOR F OUR
TAIBRNSNLEO AROOW H T TO DNGHIS
HEDAN TNUS JD KTINF O HOLONTO
ATTH AND SO ATTHTR S TEGATYNSUR
TTOUOOR WKIL UNTEST  IDOTN'
D
ENWHDO IT N'ESTS IN WHEHE T
CRLWOD ONGHAES TWHR ENNGHISO G
FROMEI BNGDA AIVPTE TO
APN-NOADVETIND ATI PARY LACURL
H
TE CEON OXTFHE TOFIN KD
RDREWA WTHS ATER EEXP INCIEED
N
ORETH WOD T T AAYNDHE KFDIN O
IVCEINNTE LESIKRU DGSNDRA ULT-
PRESS  AODFOSIT DNDIG
THCEVIS VI PATROS LDEOT OALDE
FSO
ALCIMANF IORALONTI, ETHL ES
THGSHA TT DNCVERI IASREED
DOMIPANE REAELSE TAKYHE MITE
ICPART HARULLYHED,AR T IMAY KE
A
SY TOEL DEVOPO SOM SOF T
YSWA IN,HI WCHOM SEF OHE
THHAGS TTNEAP HPET TDHA I
E K INARULRTPAICLYARMP ITAORNT
O
THR EINTI SCKNESES OS IHE T
GRDET TEEHAT' IS BOMECEULIN MDF.
YOOMRE A CYETPLELWA UNAREHA TT
EU YOAR EAGEDN IABHE T HITND A
YENOUNARE A UREWA
F O
SOMEINGST I IAR HDO T SPTO
LFURYOSERO FMOI DNGTO S
GTTGEINHTNS IIGNT IOHO TSE
TSHABIS I CGILLHAEN I ANGNDEL TL
A NYOR IOOHE T BKUT ABO TT.HA
WMYEIFND A IEREWN  INE
ZEOUD ANABEC AT DOE ADAG
GIVDRINRO FM CHUISHRTCPHRC UO T
RORLMABOH THUGH THE
S TAUNIN WD ANITAS MYST FIR
TINGRI DVIN  OE LE SID OEF
ADE THRO
OM CEP UTH TO ISRUON CST
N
AREARE W TTY HEPU YOU O ON
NI
OFHEOA RD AVE DNDRIOR F A
LECOUPILF O MES ANDT I ETSND A
SO BOI PNTON IUT D'T R
LE
THAT I ETSNDO S'M I DVING O
NH
E SEIDHEF O TFOOA RD R A
NU OERFIL MES BNT UILLYICASAL
ACOI MEUNROD TORHE CNDRNE A
THISE  AAR CYN I MAC FEUT BT I
KSSPEAO TH FACN ETVEHHO TUG I
A
EN ISNTYIY TLTRNGO TVE DRI.
BU
DTHT EY NIDECEDOTO TRY T.
SOLKE  WTA AEDOT L AHEUTBO T
A
D H BITABSRE TUTHESOS  IAL
ABODGO HS.IT
LEE SMSOOEIK GDAB HES ITAR
ERHARDREO T CHAEDAT TBAN D
BIHATSRE A SO WHY WHALDOU T
E
THE
AS CE?
CASEANIF WOHY WOU THATH BTE E
T'>> IAICES RTYNL THEAS CEND A
IT ITIERNTESUT ANGBOHE T
TBIHATSINAKG D 21SAY C TOATREE
WHS TUH RNT OUTOALAS BICLYE B
O
G THMEINDEMA UPY B A GUY
WRG INACH PSYOGOLYOO BK.
>> ISN I'T0010T ,0OU HRSR O
SO
G?THMEIN
>>LIT'HAS F TKEHEAR END O
FHA
TSBI.
ITUR T OUTOMEEN RECT WKOR
AOKLOEDLEPET OPEV DGOPELIN
OURISOO GDAB HSITND A ITK TOO
YWANROREHE FE LMIKWO TKS WEEO T
TH MURONOS S THE'S AIG B
RA
E AN HOWNT  ICAAK TE AG LON
I
E TMEOSHABSTLIOO A GD.AB HIT
ONOFHE TEA RSNSSO IHA TT
GSTHIN AREER GENLYALVE DRI BNY
FRTSO O SONTRG R WAREWDSREHEAS
TH
GSTHE INHIE W TAS ONKF D GOO
HA ATSRENG THIONWES  D
ALRET WLYANOO DE B  SS FTLOGIN
NG GOROIHEO T T, GYMHA WVETER
MTHATHTIGE. B
FDAN BL PHEROEM IHAS TT WE'T DON
GE AD  KNYINOF RNGAREWDI
OUOUESOM YON D'TAV HE T
TMIPANEP  HOELUYOAB ESTSHLIEDO
HTHATHRITAB THAGHOU TD KTINF O
PL TCITITYTHAAL I TDKEUT ABO
IEEARLOUSOR  YAV HE TO RYEL O
NT
CHR HEME AISANMS INDN
ARICRTULORHE T CNDX TEKIF O
DR
INIVGHI TSOA G D ALNDELOPG
TBIHATOUHRGHHA TTE  TYP
AT YHT MOUIGAL CLOP T
OW-N
ROCONT
'S MUS JTHUCARDE ANDAR PT
OF
WHY ITES TAK LGEONREC BSEAU
N'U YODOHAT VE KHA TT
D INF
ORSUPPTF OHETE SYSM.
N >> I TOUABTUT MENINIL IES WL
STND AE  TAKONESQUTIS, SOF I
YO
HAV QUEIOSTNSLE PEASUT P
WE GIL WLOUET YE  NRAMCA WSOE N
LEKNACOWEDG. YOU
SPBONGKI AUT GOODAB HOUSIT Y
TAEDUT ABOS THICIEW N SCTIENFI
ISPHEMASHEND A TNAAT NIO
LIN
ITUT OFHEA HLTOFOR ST
EMG.IZASIN
CAAYOU Y STL L AITBIE T MEOR
WHOUABT AT IHA TTS ANDOW H IT
RE
TOTELAS  TDESHI IA OF?AB HIT
ODAN YB HTHY AT TED T
O
AMAKED KNYINF OHA CENGHEN I T
R
ELIFELLECSPIAYOR S OTF A
THALYHA CENG I BETTT QUIGIN
SMING RT SORTAGINO TXE EISRCE
LI RLLEAZE HIFOW DCUFILT
CH
GIANNG'S ONEEH BIOAVRND A
OUABTEI BNG IN TERHE SOCEVI T
ORMESO S OTFEA HHLTOA GL.
EONHI T WNGE K AW NOISUGE
TIOPPRORON OLT HFEAHMEUT OCO
SA
D HEAHCO OUTOUSME CLDE B
ENPREVYDTE BAV BEHRIO CNGHAE.
SMGINS IY BAR FHE TNEOP T OF O
E.THOS
IFPLEOELD COUSNUS JT IR TAPHE
I
NDERNG A STO SP
KIMONG
TO,RRMOOWO S CUC MHANE BID AVOED
WHEEO PPL TRYUIO T Q
SO
GTHMEINTE B IOH ALC,OL
INSMOKGS DG,RU A TUTBO AFRDHI O
THAS LT A YREAE W'TAV HEN
GO
EN BTERT ANGEL HPIEEO PPL
FI OREUT H TOWGECHO ANHE TIR
VIBEHA SOROHAT' WHY THE NIH
HAENGOS TTESNT IERD TEINS THI
USBECA IET EANXPDSHE TFE DIFNTRE
ASSEF OSEIS DEA S ASNDWEO
E ALREIZATTHT I,OU CLDHE T
YILABITO T CHAE BE IVIHAORS
MMUCHOWEOR PFUERLN THANY A
PA DULICARATG RUTHDYNY ABO
CO
DUL D.ELEVOP
KET  IMAOT AS LF OSE SENND A
IN'SIT KOFD PR SURINISG.
IY L ILSAIN R YDIEANGOKR OUBO
TH FIRT PSTARF OT IOI GNG
THUGROH E D OAIETLSFAB H
D
LIININNKG  THEOR WKIT W
AUMNHAN AMANILSOV INDNNIVATE
CHNIITESQU WHT WHAOWE  WKN
T
THAT PTARF OOU YROO BMO IKS RE
THHREEUART TS EROFK BHEOO
HII TAU BNKECSEHE T SOND
T
HEOF TOO BK IS STOR O TFHE BIG
ONESQUTI JND AO TUS TVEGIOU Y
ITCREDREE W AOT NTE QUI
HEE
YET BUTHE TON SEC IPAD RTT WSHA
DOEO DOW NIK LEHAT
F  E
HAVE A HITAB IHA WTHES TES BT
EIESCNC TVEAYOD EWAONRYE SNT TO
OWKN ISHE TRE A MIC B NLEULT
N
OI'M I GONG T YSK ATH IOUN E
TUFUREDE LEAR.
AWH ATRE S THE TPLIME TCKRIS
E
ORIT DFOU YRIT HABS.
ERE  SE ARNOHUCEIM SPLCK TRI
.
FEON O T POISNT IRY TKEO  TMA
IS THATHA CBEINNGG VIHAORS I
HARD ANDHA TUL STHO ULED AD
O
THAVEUBROLE CGNGHAINHE TIRTT
BE
.VIHAOR
N'SOTS A IFHE TY HEAVOO PR
WI
WEPOR.
FIT'SNTDAUNMELYAL A RLLEAYAR HD
G.THIN
TH LSE' A OF UFSTFHA TST'
P ONDFEDSERENTHEN O TNDEB W AI
TH IRE PSSS TEN RMOFHO METF
GSTHINE EO PPLTGGSUES TO WK.OR
TH AE'ERSMEO LSSOTU SFFHA TT IS
IRLYELL TEPPSUOR A ADNDOT L
OF TASTHA HO TO D W THIT
NGS
DOYOU EF BEOROU YET GNT IO THE
SIIOATNE LIKGAV HIN T
RESUPPAB ASS HAU BITEC WSEEW KNO
URATTH OBI ATYLI TOON CUROLTR O
E
OVIHAORE WEND UD KPINF O
INHE T HTEAF OHE T M IENOMT
S
STJUMEUN FDAALNTLY PR.OO
ROUFR PRE CTAONLTEORXS IK WEA
WHOMT I C OESUTF OHE T
OR
UROF OAB HITTE SYSAND  THE
THGSHA TT SM,EE THI TSNG
THELRE A WLLIST EABEDSH
PA
ARICRTULIKLY LNIPLE ANNG
AH
D.EA
HEKEHEREISS  ITH ODE IA
TAEMPLENONTI ANDTT A.TIENONIM
IF ENDP U INIT A STIUAONAY S I
AMIN TRY T NGOTKE SOMO I AND
HAOO T G PO  TAHECELA W IRE AM
OFTETEN MPD TOMO S.KE
ER OINRD A TOIDVO THE OAB HIT
RO
L WWILD K IINEAF O DH WLIT
THUA SITOONTI SIND
NGANPLNI.HE AAD
THLOS E'A  OTF OERTHDE I
SATOMEE TE HAVE SOMNCVI EDEESTH
HIBENDHEM.
HEOTRESNT IERNENGTI O
S I
TATEMPONTIINUN BDLGHE W YOU
ONLL AOWR YOUTOEL SF O D
INMESOTH L YGOU DE IKTOT WOHA
OWU YOKNHOOU Y S DDNUL'TIFANO D
U YODOT ITH AT EAMEIM TE YOU
LONLYRS YETOUFELAT WCHHE T
HYTRASOWV  TSH YHE WN'ROUE O
NTH
ERE T.MIADLL
SERTHE'BE N AUMHIOFR  TSNGIK LE
THAT.
WHSHI TNG DOR'TON WNDK A WTHA
PL PDOEOTHE IN AKREHE T OIN KDF
THOUGSIN Y HREA A OUTBO,LYIOBVUS
BRADNGKI B H IITABSET SSOMNGHI
LEPEOPALKBO AUT ARE TNDHES I
VID BAADCE OUTRE THE BUT WOTHA D
YOINTHKIG MHT NOTK? WOR
NE>> OHEF O T TNGSEOPLEAV HE
EDTALK ABO AUTOT LISS  ITHDE IA
OFSUD NGEND AIV GEOGIN P
E A
THE DIG RHTONECIRTIR O MBEAY
IN GENIVM  TGHEATL LITEAR REWD
AN' S REHE I LWNO AWO OOTF RK
TH IHO SWS FFMP EORXAS TLEHI
ID
M FEAROTIDD AICRE WONHEOU Y
COYD ULPATSDD AICOT NO TAK TE
TH
E DNDGSRU AWOHA TT ELSRK W
OUSSLE YP STOGAY PINHE TMND ALUN
TTHENEC EHEFFTS TGOO WA AY.
E THERSWA AAR LDY SGETU
HA T
EDLOOK AT THETYBI ALI I AND
T
WOLO AEDS  Y ANGSOUK  WORON
INNUDGM TGHE B TEC EHEFF
TS
DIEA'TDN RYLL LAS
ROTE HE IHI TNGK TALBO AUT IN
OKE THBOSHA TT'ER INTTIESNG B
THE ERI EK INTHNCVI EDEES I
LSTIL NOTHE TRES IED MN.ATITIO
INKHI AT' ISNNT INGESERTI
TH I AGNDT MIT GHVEHAOO GD
FECTBUT THECECI SENN I TMSER
EC EOFSPLLYHINGLIS KE
RIGHT N.OW IITABSSYRE PTT SKYHA
BU TSOT' IS THIN TOUTHA Y
LALSOO KIN TETHS.AB HIT
E >>THER INT TTIESNGNGHI
BT
ITABILYF OUR OFR PRETAONLSHE
EXCORT
DO'VEYE  ANE GOO JOBNGHO SWI
HOENFFDIEROCNET URLSMIHECA
DLIKEE AMOPINICWHH ISES S ATRS
HEURNEOCHOCAMIL Y TWHEALAS BIC
Y
DEADGREHE TTYBI ALINDO  TKIF O
DOIR THEHI TNGND AT  THASCOBEME
WE I SERORDS T'HAO T DOT BH.
I'>> WONOM T IERRD TOUABTTHA SO
CHMU.
U YOGOOU THRGHHE TEN SCI OCEF
ASATWH HEE BNHO SWNO TOR WK,
WH
SN DATOE'TLL REAY WK.
OKIINNGF THEYP TES OLEPEF OP
ATHATRERET BTET ARE SE
LEPEOPRET BTE ATEA DNGLI WHIT
BEITHRIT HADABTHS AN OERTHS
LI
KEHE TIR AESLIBITIND A
RSONS ITALIEE MTOAKE SOM
OPPELE S PEOM HPLEOETTE AVBE
EE
TR-CLFONOLHA TNS.TH OER
CANIVEEEO PPL
QUNATIESONNDESIR AIKSK A L DEO
TSAU Y YNGHISOU LEGERAT RTRE
NGYI A WNDSOSEE E MEPL PEO
ESY
ICEMSTATEHLYAL BD E AVANATWH
WEL CALLSOM CPUAYEIV W ASND SO
THHISE' TSDEAHA TT
HA TT
HGHMITEAVET SOMONGHI T DH WOIT
BIROU A TTYLIOAK BREIT HAB SS,O
ESOC FUSHIN O TSA IDE O
F
POWILLATR WETHF I C WEUSLDOU J
T
REURSTSI OS,AB HITTHHA TT 'SAT
KEE Y.
NS TITURUT O RENECTES R
RCEH
ESSUGG THA MIG B NHTOTEHA WT
I
R POLLWE AISLL AUT.
DTHEYIN AIDN INRETESTG SDYTU A
EWHILGO A.
YOUIEXP EEREDNC AES DNEIR I THE
0 STLA 3 ANTMOHSTH INDF EYAI SD
ULS YEWO YDOUES RHETIS TEES DIR
ANEYTH SDAI
ES Y.
TTHENSOY HEALDIL FLE OUT A
BURES
TH NCOFSEHO QNNSTUEIO
CLWHO MSAIO TAV HE
IG HH
-CSELFTRONOLND AOEHO W DND'TSN A
LP WIFILASEROW WBO AUTTIES RISNG
S,URGEOUOU Y WNK TLDHIHE
ITLEOP WF- SHELLNTCOROOU WLD
OINGHROUGH W THELDOR
RE
G STSIINRGETH UMO IES RE
EFY IVCTELTBU IHA TT'TSNHA WT
THEY FNDOU.
LEPEOP WIGHIT HHLP WIL AEROW
ND
WLOIL W,OWLPERBAHE TY YCASILL
CLM TOT.ES RIS
TH DBIE GNCFEIFRE WEASHE T
PET  TLEHAOOVEHA GD
TR-CLFONOLAV HERGO N UNE I
E
RSFIEPLT ACND AS IT'ANEL REVT TO
K WEORANG AELORUC DKW
HS
DONEGE SUG TINSTGYHERE A
ULRTPAICOOLYAR GATD EVELINOPG
ABODGO HSITND ABA PROIKYBL LE
NELODER VEE D PETHDBA HITABS
EI BNGBL AE AO THEIDVO T
TIMPTETA IONNHE TIR FCE PSTLA.
A.
T >>INT LHEASERHA CPTURF OYO
YOKBO,K  TOUALTHOUABT ISLA PCE
A
EDLLNGAC HKIHEND A T
SCIFNTIC I TIGNSHTIKTHA L TEHE
VARELE TE NCTOHE BRAVEHIO
GECHAN.
LLOF AF ONEHE T OYOS U
MED,IONTNEHAT  YOUHI TNKS I
PMOSTNGMIROSIIST  ATH
PAULICAROI P INTNE? TIM
USMET  JAYT STHHA WT E MENU
IS
GS D'SRUHA TTAN C ESERA
RIMEMO OESRTI PARLACUR KFDIN O
ALVIHAORIQEC THNATS UETH
N
OMLPHE SEF O THE SFFTUHA T
ORVEU' WD ON TO TER TRYO EASYO
RIMEMO OESRLATI SMUFONTI OHE T
BRG USN INTUISTH SFFE WL CAL
GEHACSTI TS  UTSEGHLITO T
CRHETEEA TEU NNSRO.
HE'SIT TT MOSSERE PCIY F  OAN
H
CHTHE ELEALNG WLILEAU BECSE I
E
BIRQUESURINRA SNDRYGE AENE
YERTHAP TUT PONHE T I CSNNHAEL
INK THI INMS TER SF ONGETOMHI
'STHATSTLO CSE TO BEANGEI RYLL
ABPLAPIC T ILENLD WHEOR I
K
ALACTU TLYHEOFIN KD IQEC THNSUE
OUATTH YDOR WKEIT W
'S AAS B TALICLYHEAU C OSEF
USEHA WT WENO KWBO AUTIEEM MORSA
EH STOOMRU DOWIS THAOR MEM
YE
WEUSCAE RN LEAEDOU THRGHK WOR
FR O L AOTPL PFEO IENHE TT LAS
O
F LEUP OSCADEDET THA IT
BESMEBLNS UTANE WEHEOURVE Y
REHEVEIE TMND AAN C TAU CSEMHE
ETO B DD.RAEGDE
FOR TRI PMEUTEIM BT' IS THEN R
T LEASE IESCNCN CTFIIO AOFLLF O
TH.
ND ATHEEA LSTIVNV IAS
T
NGHAVIKE WORD TN ISHI ARE I
ERE RETHEVES  ISELRAFE DIFNTRE
TYEMOFS  MD Y ORANWHOOU Y
ETTARGHE T RHT ONEO TEL T ULS
IS THT RHEIGVENT IER BIONTNUT I
WOD BEXC ENDEDIT AERSOLLY
N
ISTVEEDNT THARCES REAH.
OK T S,OE MWOORIOUE QSTNS FOR
U.
ATWHURS  IYOOR WST HITAB?
C>> ILDOU GO G METY WEIF AND
ASR.HE
IT'SESNT IER
NGTI.
YOW, KNO IE'VN BEEYRE PTTOO GD
AVI H'TEN G RTEOTNFID OE  WINDAN
OV CIDTAS HN'EL HDPEHA TTYO S M
BAABD H IITSBLRO PBA DYGNKRIIN
MIE  WINANTH IUL SHOND A I
KNHELL A T T ONGHISNEDHO SUL
ADONDIMOM SET I'MSSUC SCELFU
ENWH IID DECEHO I SDNUL'TNK DRI
H MASUC WHI TSMK EEI'UCCEFUL
ATNGOIHA TTUT B A OLLFY M
E LEOWDG T HOFOWIT HHEAB
EMSYSTORKSASN'TEDND EOWE M
THWI KNY AD OFOW PERN WHET I
DIYO U EL'TDN TUSL EA A RYLL
ODB MA SNEO EEYB WFOIL WL OW
LASTUE Q AIOSTNNDN THE WEIL WL
GO TO TEN AHETT
ESDE.
INIMAGE THAT' IS5, 204 D04 26,O
THYOU KINHE T BEHIOR  OANCHGE
TWE TRYORE BAK TADSEHE BSAB HIT
ECABEUSY THEADRE A BOR OUR
HE R ATHND TATELEDOHI TSNG
KE CCERND ART HEAIS DOSEEA D
THYOU EKIN W HOU WLDDEE AVMA A
OFT NI SIGCANTRO PESGRS
E T OUTHEIESCNCINVO ELVIN AAB
WAYHA TTOE DSOM BEC PEALCTRAIC
EORFO PEPL INIR THEDAVE ERYY
S?LIVE
>> I THI TNKTHA I AMRTN IPA
ECABEUSHE TRE I ASN ONGNGOI
CH
NGEAN IOW HE EO PPLEAR
TIARNG TOHI TNKBO AUTHE TT
S UDSTIEDANHE TACPP ARO THO
STAV BYEHRIOHANG L TEHETAS
TFOURO DIV FE HADECESN'T
ODIE TET GHEO T TEC MSNIHASM
ANEOOW N PEPL AREINHI TNKMOG RE
TABOUHA T ITN THEEN SCI
OCF
VIBEHA CHAE SO IHI TNK
N I
SAE ME M WAYTOINOVG RDWAS
TR TNGOSTND UERHEDAN T
MOMELACUR MSANCHISFANCER
OUBRBOTGH A NUTEWAT TRENTMES
ATTHAN C SRE TATC CIPEFISNCCAER
BAHEOND  TXA ELO BCTIO OGYF
TH WNCCAER CEANAV HHEE TE SAM
PRSSREND UDISTERANAV BNGEHRIO
.ANCHGE
>>OP HE
SO.
LL'SIT A I DT TIDHA I TTOKOO S
LOCOO  TREIZGNE THETAMP IORENC
AJ AAS MLT HOREAHER INTNNTVEIO
BU OLYIOBVUST I IS AAJ M
ORHED
NTTHAL IIOVEERNT IANN D'M
WERE SG RTTAINUS FTOOCN O IT.
NOTOINGOG TH OERUE Q
IOSS
TFROMEN AHETTISESDE,  AHE TRE
ENFFDIERCEN I A GERDOO VDS SUBA
T?BI
>>TIERNTES.NG
DON'KNOWSEF  ORENCHAR O
TH
.IS
ITINTU CELIVY,LYTAERINHE TRE IS
N
D IT PARE LIKHE T TIR FSTNGHI
ON IARLENSN A SONUAITTI
BEES METHAU DEFLTEH B
IO.
GOODIT HABNOARS E NG GTOI TOE B
THTHRSFIT G YOLEARINN  A
ATSITU TN IOSOYHEEN GALERLY
COBEE  MMEORULFFDIICT CO TATREE
LANDSESY IK LELE  CTOOMNDCKBA A
STKD.RO AUN
TI EDOMO MS ONORDOOOS PIVITE
IVEG NATEEH BFALE C H
IS
CTHATNGHAE AND WAIT HABRN
S URNEONHAESDO TT INVVEOL?
ONMO ETIS, MD,OOHTHO TUGLLS, A
ESTHNG TEHIOM BSECTSHAE BIIK LE
VIBEHASORAN C
EYRO P RBLBAYY ELONFE DIFNTRE
BRYSNAI S
MSTE.
VEYOU'AON DE FOT L O WKORN ONE
ICPARTARULMO EONTI, FREA TND AHE
BREMSYN STLVINS VO IEDN
HT
BEMINGTION CDINDEDON A
ULTEMALY HITAB SO TREHE
NLRTCEAIARY E IND A KON D'TWNO
ATWHHE TMSYS STEOU WLD BE BUT
EMION D  KISIN AOF FNG-FARLU
BUINTHG TA CTERT LYIN IIS THE
CA WUN HEYO TNKHIUT ABO IT
BSKELI O-CSIESVEIVPUOMLS
E
ERSODIRD TT' ISRE EHEXT
IORSNF OHO T BHTUGSGOMECINEVE
T HABI TSOHEOM AYUTLYICATAL
UANTCOINORYLL ST OFET RATRE.
O>> IONENFT WRDE TOHAT
,TEEXNTRE THES IINNE O FNGDIUT O
THT' TEHA GAT FSE TORHOF O
S
ET GLDNGTI OT TERHAHE TER OLD
YOET GHEE MORIVOS PITE
KTLOUOOAVOU Y HANE D T
T HS
RTPALY DUEO TOUOW H YPRNT IERET
IS A GALSSLA HFL FULR OTY EMP
ISAND  AHA TT HORITAB FPL PEO
EF
OU D IT A LOT
S TSOHI INS ANO AMONYUSEN ATTEDE
T'TBU INEARND DREAO TY M
ARHET B IAUECSE'MCTUAOIYLL G
TUGROHE SHEAMHI TNGT WHA I
A
TESTRAGYCR TO TEEA AOSITEIV
HAT FOR G OTIETNG'SNEREHI CLD
CT PTORAEICIA PNO A ORGTHNYIN
TH D'TONEE SN S  AFUER FOTH
NGLOER TM?
ETHRT SHO ANSWER  IISAV H NEO
ID.EA
E >>THONESQUTIW S IHO YDOOU
MAHE TMIV MOTEDAT TO DO ITN O
THN,R EIOWNOUN F EEWHUG RDSAR
COD PLOL AAY RE T INTHA AND
E'THERTH ASNOER IERNTTIESNG
QUBOONTI ARE WUTHEES  ITH
REM FROIK LE THECE SUCSS O
INPLAYG A PNO.
N'I DOT THI TNK AREHE'S
NY
E IESCNC R TONHEAREWDF O
SU
ESCCS.
ITHATANS ESNT IERUENGTI QIOSTN.
HI I>> T IFOU CE CANOM UP
KELIOWO  TKN.AWENSR, IOU WLD
S ISTH IOMFRLI WILAM BWERER.
MISEABNTSSEDNDNE ASSRO PFEOR
ES
GOANO  TCHO IGENTMA FOR
FOHEOTS  C ACEONRTISND A HLCL
FE FIMDSIN H I HNISAM PAJ.AS
DO
YOUAV HECON  AACT?UN
LKI  TA ABO AUT SIOCTNPSLI IN
OOETH B AKND THIS T I IA
GRT EMPLEF O THE PEROW OF
TH OKIE NDFXT EDEEND RS.TIOUNE
H
THINTHATESEC BOMYEA RLL
DIINULICT AK BREGINAB HSITS
'V YCEOURT SETAED THEOU RNETI,
ITESEC BOMDL MINS.ES
ADE'V H EHI TSNCERXPIE OF
WAY HE,OMTI GETNGOM HE ANDEN THE
REWEINIZG GO FORTO SP AT
TH PECCELA BSEAU R THETOO OF
INGETTHOG ME HASE EC BOMNCHSU A
AUTIMACIT HABLUA T
NGHI.
E'THERAS  L OOTFER INTTIESNG
NCSCIE OENS. THI
ATIT TNGHISE LIK H TOWHE
VIACTIS GTYOERO FMEI BNG
INCONTUS TOUGHHE T WLEHO
ORHABEVITAO T S AINRTGT THE
BE
GNNGIINND AHEN BLYICASAL
DOINRTHG EI RHO WLE.TIOUNEN DE
SO THANKHI TT T AREHE'SOO GD
EXN ATANIOMS TINEREF  OTHIN KD
OFINHU CNKET TGOGRHE OF
THE
E WHOL ONCBUHAV BFEHRSIO TO A
EUTROINBEHA TT AUMECOS CMATOTI
AS AHO W.LE
T S>>O,T NHEEXIOUE QST INHI T
H
ELE WHO BOOAB IKS HITOU TS
TIQUES BONUT I WETLIL L
ES T
ATAKETA SBT AT. I
THANYOK U FOR TER IHENTTIESNG
ERCONV.TISAON
ARERTHE BCALOIOGILCLBS OTA
EO
'SHE TRE L AOT OFS WAYO T
TH
OUK INABTT. THA
I AESONEN MTI,ED THEEL RIVATE
ITAGFRIL T OYF PHETAFRREON
CONE WEXHEERVE W NODEE TRT EXE
COL,ROE WAVEO T RYEL AND
AS'SIT ESRY ILDITEUPD BYS,TR SES
LA OFLE SEPND A OOT LS
FDI
ERENNG THIS TO ST'HAS
AICERTROYNL PBLY THE BGEIGST
ON
TANE DNHE T IHENKHI TTH OER
PHCALOIOGIK THL INOF IT AS AN
LESTOBACEGHE T DERE TO WECHHI W
NVEOW IN EN AMEIRNVONT TNTHA
ATIMSTUL UESS IN WHASAY T
OR
NSBRAIER WEOT NES D TNEIGDO DLEA
OTHWI SUF  IYOAK T AE LOTF O
DI DENERTGSRU LEIKNEOC CAIND A
AMPHAMINY TESHEURAN C T
OU YRINOP DAMETE SYS
BMUT
'STHATR O  SFAETSOUIDF O OUR
ENPEEXRI WCEE ARE NOTIP EQUDPE
TOTHL EAWI SHO TSETOR OF
TH.GS
>> HOWUO DYOINXP ELA FAIRE
EATO WR AAS MK INMS TERF OIT HAB
WHOWHE T DISIDNSE O SAR CLE?
HI>> TISS NT INGESERTIND A
TINPOTS SNGETOMHIT THA I D'TON
PTEXCEHE WN T IKAL CBO AUTMALITE
GECHAN AND BOV CID IUTTAS H TO
H WDOITNO AAYERTH L OERF
BEHAORVI CHIENG W T HCHASDOO
HETHWI TIN KD OFETIN MDSND A
SLIBEEFND AOL IDEIES.
OUIF Y BON D'T YIEELVED NOUEEO T
GECHANEHER H BIOAVR THA TNREHE
NISO NDEE TO.
S
THHEALETHY ERO AS W NOEDNE T
STOPO S TSSHI IIG HIGHT BHOT
TINHE CTEONXT OF ASKI-NTMA
S
VONE ASIERONNDITPP OOS TNIOO
IANCHGESERNO ATH.
ANFOR D  KYINNG COFHAE TO
ENHAPPETH, ERAS H TE B
SENDT ORFEL BIEDRHA TT ESIVMI
TH CAT ANGHAECO INDT DUL BE
FUHELP
L.
T ABOUDEDEA CAGO A I AAD ME
CHGE IY MIE DT, VIAETEGAR
NI
B  CGHARRFO ALE WHI AND
DCIDEDEANO  TCH MGEYT  DIE
T
THE TWE SSDEND AOM BECEA AE MT
EA-C LNGOWUTBAR NTND A I
WO T BEDUTMAO KET IOR WK I HAD
SUR CRINAVGSE LIKZY CRA.
MWHATE I WORHA IKS HENGVI T
TNDMISEFHI T T ISSHEAY W I
O VEHA TFTEA I IT WANO TE B
ATHALYT  TNDHAATANTRSLES TMHE
IKTOIN L YOUAI S
TDHE
VAMOTIO ONTI T TDOHEHI TOUSNG Y
THNEYOK U EDO O T D HT BUITAS
O
FOM CE TMROTHA H MHLIGYDSINET
SOHI TSHO WLE SIETA MLOMTEN
JUIN KDHI OF TILIGHGH
TE
ANPOIMRT OCEF TT.HA
>>THO IS GS BOKAC TNO AERTH
U
TIESON.
WHOL RE HOE DSANUM I
ENNTT
INLADEY  GTIETNGID R HF OITAB?
'S ITER INT.TIESNG
THESGUS TFIE RSST QUENIOS I
OLATWH RS DEOEDNT IENO TLA PNY I
R BR.AVEHIO
EREV TODYBYNKHISN WHEDOHE TY
GSTHINHEN I TORLDHEY EAR
DO
TGINMHEEC BHESEAU TT WYANO
DO IM HEORTOENNTD O DHE TM.
THALAS BIC T TLYRYNT QOUAYIF
ENWHE EO PPLNG TDOHIARS EHE TY
DO
EMG INTHSEEC BAUHE TY WTAN T
AU BEC TSE DY'HEVEE
HE M
REBEFO ANDT I T ONEURD L AUT
OF
BAVIO IS TECOACUNFOD R BY
FATHE T TCTHAT' IS AIT HAB
.
SIT'SNGETOMHIEOU Y'VON DE
PR IUSIOLYTHN EE SAMTIIT SUA
FIRSTVE EGTHRYINOE W D
S
AFROMEN INTSNONTI I T'THE
VIBEHA.ORTHI TNK AUTBOAN HUM
ONPS FHELIHEEID T ITU SFFE'VTABT
TAUT AEDBOIK LEMEMP ILENATNTIO
E WHERUYOHI TNKBO AT  WUTHALLWI
ITH ION ISCUAR PTIRLA
ATSITUHAN,IO TSTUT RN TUT O
E
AEL WESTAISHEDETHO
SU
NGESGGTIT I CAN HPELEOPL
TANCHGEEHIRHE B SIOAVROSHA TT'
ACA PL WEF REHE IUS IITS  IEDN
THEIG RHTAY W AND H IEOP I'M
GE
ATINTTG HE TST QUESNEIOR'
NTINTE TUT B IHANKHI TIST  A
E WHE  CITAN BD UESEN I
GHE THRITAY TOEL HAV BPEHRIO
RKWO.
HA>> WHEIST TTFF EECF O A
ANCOMPN ORPOEUSKIN  IMANGR O
NGEABRKI AIT HAB
T'>> IS LIKE ANER EXTLNA
PR CNTROAL
TEORX.
TEAU[LGHR]
OONEFHE TARD PTSARBO AUT
BR HKIEANGSITAB IZIEA RLI
U
DOARE GIN THE.HI TNG
KINDF O G ITIETNGIGNSHTNTO
LI I   BD SETOEITY M
NANGFIERSIL AND IN' DIDIZRET AL
T
US JT D ITVIO  SHAPO ANG SEUS
ATTHS I SINAYGIL W S YLOUPTO
GDOIN HHA TTOUPSEL Y TAI GNHE
TSIINGHO INTREHE T FENQUCYIT WH
WH D YHOU IOT AND HT IPS
GIOU YATOT MIVN.IO
VEI NEHADIV MOTIOATN TOOT N
MTEYGE FIN TAIRNLSHETHA WN I BE
E
IIZALEDYEANT NOD W MYEIF I
CHAN.GEATOT MIVN IOTOTHAK ME E
SIE THINDT GHANATOT MIVRENIO A
BO
THSP ATS.
>>OVI L ETHE ATLERXTNA
EFPRNTROALTE COR
LINEGERATIZAONIM DSISINHEE SOM
OFTHAPL PEOEEL BVEIE F INERE
OICHCE F ANDEREL. WIL
DO B YOU IIEELVEFRN EE WL?IL
O >> DIE HAV TONS AHARWE TT
QU?TIESON
D Y>>OU HNOO TOEAV TNS AR.WE
HI I>> TNK H IEAVE FREL. WIL
AESTHEREHE T KFDIN OIOUE QST
Y I TRTO T TPE SNDHIEIM T
G
TABOU BECSE I KON D'TATW NOTH
THRE A ABLWENSRA
I AEYRETIERNTES I ANGNDIK LE
EATO ROSPHD IL THEOPRSKALBO AUT
TH.
I KINHE W INAK ME CICHOES I
DOCAN SHI TNGN O MY EEFRIL WL
DOT BUI OWT N'KNOOW H T
SCICNTIEIFLYALSTABSHLIHA TT.
HE>> TNOT MIOOU YNUON CTI
TSBIVE ENN WHEN'T  IIST YROUA
IN
NNTTEIOT IOE D'TSNN MEA TREHE
FRN'IST L  WEEILITUS JTNS MEAE W
T E ARNOWAALYSCTINOR ACCNGDI.
HE>> TTH IRES A IISDEATTHOM C
R
OM A FEON W'T AND IEL BVEIE
THAI VELI AHEBITYO T NOT DO
SOI INTHG INS WAGOTOG  DOY B
ORCFOE,WIF LLVEHA WTET TRHAS. I
I>> DNO'TON KHIANW YTNG AUTBOSI
EVORCEEN FAIR  OAGTNSHA TT.
ILWE  WLTWAK TE .MOO RE
SOYSE ONSAHA TNKOUOR F A
TAEAGRT .LK
BIN VEHA TOSTABSHLI
M-TNGER GOALSLI IMPTCI FORO
INEWCTRE RULD ARWO YDOU
REAENMMD AY WO TRI BNGDSEW RAR
CL TEROHE T PNTSIREDE OR MEOR
ITPLEXICN W,HEINTA SRTTO
DEP LOA NEW?AB HIT
I IHI TNKT ISUI BLT O TSA IDE
ATTH TOU YABKEALD R T OUFOETH
IT HODABHES T'SREEAOT N R AYLL
E
RDWA.
IT'SER INTTIESNG T TNKHAS,THA
AISAT GRE QN.STUEIO
IG'SIT RE LHTIKO HY W DSFLI OS
IIG NHT'MOI DT  TNGHAIN
SEFEIC OAR R AEW ITHD AT'TSN
INGOGO TOM CEOR FEA YRSN DOWHE T
RO PSO, MENTOIOW DHE TOA RD.
OFONE HE THI TESNG WNO KWUT ABO
TUREDSEW RARHAS I T ATHT EYRE
MMUCHEORUR OIN MDSRE TAT TMHE
AS MEORTR ABSTACHA TN ITEEDMMIA
M
E DIMEATISOM SHIETNGBLAN TGI
ETHON LTEG RMDEW RAR OFOT N
SON WHENG THIEEO PPL TAABS SUGHT
AB THIT SGNKHIINAVF O HGIN
EP
IODISESHEN TUR FUTDIPI ESO
LKIINNGOEIE  MAK IINTHGS
E
REFUTUOR ME ITEEDMMIA.
ENEVIDTH OCEN  IATHI TNKS IOT N
LYALAT GREET Y.
I  SN'VETNYNEE A ESHABSTLIED
EV,ENIDCEUT B T ITHA I OSNEADE
OUABTOW H TOTIOT PENAKLYAL M
ETE
EOSGE LONTERMAR REWDSF
TSHABI SOR ME IIEALNT STHN ERTHO
.TERM
S>>OAS LTST QUE ANION TNDHE I
WIDD AOMO T S THIETNGO THE
D
OFHE TIOUE QSTNEL REDAT.
DOHOW OU YOV MERO FMAV HNGIN A
EXALRNRE PL ONFRTARTCOEXND A
TAINGE HER AUTBOOU YLT ANGDUS
COBENGMIEP INDNTENE WNO K TWHE
R
ALROEFNTXOR CTEOPEV DEL
SRE
TIVE LATARCOE MP TEDO T
E
T OSTFHE ARA BINND TSREHE I
SODE EVIENC TGE SOUGST
THE
RDREWAMSYS STEEV DOPEL ELYAR IT
LAREOSTE TMPHE T I
SIULVE
VIBEHAOR WHA TTE SEEHE T
ESQUF ONTI OW TOPTIMATE IZTH
IS A GDOO O I ANENDON DNK T'THI
ANNOYOD KWSHE TR NS AWETO
.THAT
ONF O THENG THIT TSHAS I
RFPOWE T IN E ADNTESOLCEISS
SONFALCI I TENLUCETHA
NTESOLCE PARS ELATIARCUYRL
WI
TINLLGOE TAKIS RKS DND AO
LSIMPUINE IVTH IGSNHE TTE CON
F
OFIN KD EE PR PESSREUR WEAN C
SECHOOUR O KSID F BENRIDSUT
I
KTHIN IST'D KINF OND USTANNG
THAT ANDAY MTR BE ONGYI T
HIGHLIT TOHE TEG DEOHI WCH
PEERURRE PSSHT MEIGE B W ONEAY
HITO TUT ANKBOHA TT.
EFORWE CSELO, D YOOUE HAV
ANLSNGHI E YEOUTOAN WT AY S
AB
I THITGHOUT AS WER TFIRIC.
REO PHAEPL TLL RTEAYAN WTOT
UN
NDRSDETAHE TEN SCI, IN TMSER
T' WOFHAENHAS PP IGINNHE T
N
YWHEN TOURY TO SHEPTO T
IN BDUVIALRSAVEHIOND ARE WHE
WEEN PANOT GALTILYINO HE T
REFUTUASHE T EH WEITHI WOUCH Y
BLREWE AEO TVE CON TYHE
CAMPCOLICIDTE SCEENEH BDIN
HA
T.BI
NGYTANHILS EEOU Y WTANO TAY S?
I  AATREPPCIEHA TT A THAST'
ACEXATY TLWHTR'V IE ODIE TO D
URTHWI OSSIS DCUASNIO H DON A
GOIGOB J HINIGHLHTG A TLLHE
FFDI TENERTINNGHIS HE TOO BK.
YOANTHK U BHOTOR F
HI TS
INATG DIONUSSCSIND A I
ALAN WT TONK THAONVE ERYT TEHA
JOED USS THINGVE ENI.
NYIF AOUEON WE  LLDIKTOEA LRN
MOIE C,OPSRE AIL AVANLEAB O
D.RVHAARM COONINHE T LHAKS T
T
BVEI'NEEUT PNGTI TN I C
.
SOHAN  OBELF H OFVAARRD
BO TORSTE, DIVIONF O
EIESCNCND AARHE T HRDVARYIB LRA
HA A GDOOVE ENGNIBOVE ERY.DY
KEDI REANG P AND PASLEE,ASLEE
L. WBEEL
KTHAN. Y